[موسيقى]
انها ثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياض انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
البيت الابيض يكشف عن تصاعدي التوتر بين
موسكو وفاكنر ويتهم الاخيره بالسعي لكسب
اهميه السياسيه عبر ساحه المعركه
البرلمان الاوروبي يدعو لادراج خامنئي
ورئيسي على قوائم العقوبات والحرس الثوري
على قوائم الارهاب
معركه نتنياهو مع القضاء تستعر بعد الغاء
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه تعيين درعي
وزيرا في الحكومه
بعد ازمه الركوج شبحوا الجوع يخيم على
اعمال منتدى دابوس مجاعه غير مسبوقه تدق
ناقوس الخطر في العالم
[موسيقى]
مسكته مؤقتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
وقبل ان نفتح ملفاتنا نبدا بهذه التصريحات
اللافته من البيت الابيض حول ملفنا الاول
حرب اوكرانيا فقد قال مستشار البيت الابيض
للامن القومي جون كربي ان المخابرات
الامريكيه تقدر تصاعدي التوتر بين وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ومجموعه فاجنر واقل كيربي
ان يفقديني بريجوزين مؤسس فاجنر يريد
اكتساب الاهميه السياسيه من خلال
الانتصارات في ساحه المعركه وكان مؤسس
وفاجنر ظهر اليوم وهو يمنح عفوا لمدانيين
رؤوس بعد ان شاركوا في الحرب في اوكرانيا
ورفض الاجابه عن سؤال صحيفه
مصدر سلطته لمنح عفوا لمجرمين مدانين وقبل
ايام انتقد مؤسسه فاجنر وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه بعد اعلانها السيطره على مدينه
فوليدار وقال ان قوته هي من سيطرت على
المدينه لتخرج بعد ذلك وزاره الدفاع وتؤكد
انها تثمن مشاركه فاجنر في المعركه
وبين روسيا واوكرانيا كل المؤشرات الراهنه
لا تعكس سوى ان الامور ذاهبه باتجاه مزيد
من التصعيد في الصراع وغياب امال السلام
حتى تصريحات المسؤولين الرؤوس والاكرام
والغربيين كلها تصب في رؤيه واحده حرب
طويله الامل وسواء كان الامر تهديدا كما
تفعل موسكو او توقعا كما يرجح الغرب
فالمعارك هو الهجمات هو الاحداث تعكس هذا
السيناريو فمثلا سقوط مروحيه وزير
الداخليه الاوكرانيه اليوم وما سيترتب على
نتائج التحقيق في اسباب الحادث سيدفعوا
بلا شك الامور الى تصعيد الاخر كيف الان
في جمع الادله واثار سقوط مروحيه الوزير
على حضانه اطفال بينما روسيا منشغله
التحضير لمعركه في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
رسومات
على صوت صفير في البدايه كان هناك صوت
صفير ولكن لم يكن هناك انذار بغاره جويه
نظرت الى هاتفي ولم يكن هناك اي تنبيه
وبعد ذلك
احمرا متوهجا يسقط فوق الحضانه اعتقدته
البدايه انه صاروخ لان كل شيء وكانت هناك
شضايا تتساقط في كل مكان نظرته عبر
النافذه مره اخرى ورايت وجوده
الدول
شو ماكو دبلوماسيه السابق مرحبا بكما
ضيفيه الكريمين استاذ ايلين ابدا معك قبل
الحديث على تحطم مروحيه الوزير وزير
الداخليه الاوكراني داعيني اسالك عن تعليق
البيت الابيض المتحدث جون كربي يتحدث عن
ازمه ربما اوتوتر في العلاقه بين موسكو
ومجموعه فاكنر هل هناك حقا توتر بين همم
بين السلطه في موسكو وهذه المجموعه التي
تقاتل على الارض واستعانه بها روسيا
وتستعين بها في المعارك الدائره حاليا
روسيا هو هو همم
الولاء الكامل لرئيس بوتين وهو الان
القائد الاعلى للجيش الروسي فعندما نتحدث
عن هذا الولاء هو المقصود انه الولاء
لرئيس نفسه فاذا حتى اذا كان هناك خلافات
ما بين وزاره الدفاع وهو اعتراض هذا يعني
انه هناك خلافات ما بين رئيس
يبدو انه ياخذ المزيد من السلطات لماذا هل
هذا بسبب النجاحات التي تحققها فاجن ربما
اكثر من القوات النظاميه الروسيه ام ماذا
واخذ المزيد من صلاحيات لانه رئيس بوتين
سمح لهذا الشيء وهذا اثار غيره يمكن من
قبل
الاخرين ولكن النظام هو النظام العسكري
لازم يبقى نظاما عسكريا فالان كل الامور
العسكريه تحت اشراف وزير الدفاع ورئيس
الاركان ورئيس الاركان سيد جلاسمه فاصبح
الان قائدا للقوات الروسيه العامه في
اوكرانيا
مشكله مع وزير الدفاع ولكن يبقى ولاؤها
للرئيس سيد شو ماكو في كيف اسالك اليوم عن
ااه تحطم مروحيه وزير الداخليه الاوكراني
وسقوطها على حضانه اطفال هل روسيا وراء
هذا الحادث
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
شخصيه
[موسيقى]
موجود تقريبا 14
محاولات لاختياله
يعني
اكيد نحن ننتظر الرسمي هو تقرير من لجنه
المحققين ولكن من وجهه نظري انا
ممكن استخبارات روسيه شاركت في هذه
المناسب حول السيد فريق جوش سيد كراسي
موجز بالمناسبه كلاهما اعداء علاوه الى
هذا الداخل روسيا موجود ليس فقط امواج
ناركمان او وجود مجموعه
يعني نحن كمان نشهده عن سوف يكون او يكون
الان صراع بين
الجيش الروسي
كبيره
انه يبدو انه يمكن حقيقه ان يكون هناك
خلافات ولكن ستريج المؤسس مجموعه يبقى
ولاءه همم غير محل للشك للرئيس العظيم
نعم نعم ولكن كمان كنت عندكم الان اظهرت
ااا طموحات السياسيه واقتصاديه بالمناسبه
وبعضهم موجود اشتباكات مع سياسيين الروس
هو خاصه
مروحيه وزير الداخليه الاوكراني اليوم
مقتله طبعا اضافه الى عدد اخر من الاشخاص
طبعا من الضحايا
التحقيق لم ينتهي بعد صحيح همم يعني هناك
لان تكون روسيا قد تكون هي التي استهدفت
وزير الداخليه الاوكراني لكن الظروف تبدو
همم مريبه نوعا ما همم هل يعني الا يمكن
ان تكون روسيا هي التي قامت بتصفيه وزير
الداخليه الاخرى
لا انا قطعن استبعد ذلك رؤوس لم تستهدف
اشخاص سياسيه وقيدات حكوميه في اوكرانيا
وبهذا السبب بعض المؤيدين لهذه العمليه قد
وجعوا عده مرات انتقادات للقياده السياسيه
والعسكريه الروسيه ولكن روسيا لن تفعل ذلك
ولم تفعل ذلك
العمليه العسكريه وحتى همم اوكرانيين وهم
يذكرون اكثر من سبب هو اكثر من فرضيه مثلا
ما كانت هناك اناره لابراج سكنيه عاليه
وفي ظروف المواجهه العسكريه هذا الحكمدار
همم طياره يمكن لما يتبع بوجود بنايات
عاليه وهذا سبب سقوط هذا الحكم
نعم طيب ايه سيد شو ماكو في كيف ماذا لو
ثبت ان روسيا عن الحالتين اذا كانت هي
وراء الحادث ام لا اصلا هناك توتر كبير
ونذر مسار تصعيدي وتحول في الحرب بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا
الى اي حد يمكن ان تنعطف او ينعطف مسار
هذه الحرب
بصراحه
مرحله جديده في الصعيد
الوزير الداخليه ولكن كما كنت همم انتظر
وتصريحات رسميه وتقارير من
اللجنه التفتيش والمحققين هنا في اوكرانيا
ولكن على كل حال نحن سوف نشهده حتى هنا
همم
روسيا من المعروف يعني روسيا سوف افتتحقق
ايضا تعبير جزئيه او خطا تعبئه عام جديده
ولكن هذا بعض شهر شهرين ولكن نحن نرشده
يعني روسي قواتها كما في جنوب اوك يعني هو
كمان همم
لماذا لان السيد يفوت ان هو انتقامي جدا
يعني روست فاشل هذا حرف هو في حاله
بالمناسبه هزيمه روسيا في هذا حركها بعد
قليل من روسيا سوف تهاجم مره ثانيه ومره
ولذلك الصيغه الظاهريه لاوكرانيا هذا
الطرد الروسي من اراد اوكرانيه وبعد ذلك
انضمام
ان الناطر هذا الضمان
اوكرانيا عماره ثانيه استاذه الينا
سوفلينا في اخر سؤال لك حلفاء اوكرانيا
الغربيين يستمرون في دعمها بانواع باسلحه
جديده لدينا الدبابات البريطانيه الفرنسيه
اضافه الى الامريكيه وغيرها كذلك من
الاسلحه هناك حديث على اقتراب مشاركه بلا
روسيا في الحرب الى جانب القوه الروسيه
وكما اشرنا قوه فاجنر قوه الشيشانيه
وغيرها من القوات الاخرى تستعين بها روسيا
هل سنشهد حرب دبابات مثل حرب العالم مثل
معركه الدبابات التي شهدناها في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
لا على كلن المعارك تبع اليوم هي تغيرت
حتى طبيعه جرحها وقتل الان تشير الى انه
اكثريه الجرح وقتلها لديهم شظايا من
صواريخ وقذائف
هذه هي المواجهه عن بعد اكثر ما هي
مواجهات مباشره من المهمه لكن انه هناك
تغيرعي في امدادات الاسلحه ممكن ان يتم من
الغرب الى اوكرانيا وهذا مقلق ولكن رغم
ذلك انه سيتحقق بعد الانجازات الان في شرق
اوكرانيا
الكريمين من موسكو السياسيه في مركز
الدراسه الدوليه الينا سفولينا ومنكير في
الاردن
وبينما تتصاعد الحرب في اوكرانيا يبدو ان
الحل الديبلوماسيه قد لا يجد له مكانا في
هذا الصراع الدائري بين الجانبين فمقترح
الجلوس الى طاوله التفاوض ظل يتردد على
السنه المسؤولين دون ان يتحول الى واقع
ملموس وقد يذهب ادراج الرياح والتحديد
العسكري الاخير وهو ما المح له وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه مشيرا الى ان التفاوض
ليس مطروحا على المدى القريب على الاقل لا
ظروف قال ان موسكو لم ترى بعده اي مقترحات
جاده لاقرار السلام في اوكرانيا مضيفانا
افكر الرئيس الاوكراني بشان هذا الموضوع
غير مقبوله ولن تجري موسكو معه اي محادثه
اغلق الباب امام فرصه في تفاوض ليفتح نائب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي بمتري ميدف نافذه
جديده للسلام لكن بشروط لن تتنازل عنها
موسكو الفيلم اعاده الحديثه عن مساله
الاعتراف بالمناطق الاربعه التي سيطرت
عليها روسيا في اوكرانيا كشرط اول كما دعا
الى ضروره توحيد الرئه حول بنود المواثيق
الدوليه
روسيه تضع شروطا للتفاوض مع اوكرانيا
وحلفائها
اولا الاعتراف بنتائج استفتاء ضم المناطق
الاربعه الاوكرانيه
ثانيا صيغته قواعد دوليه تتلائم مع
المعطيات الجديده للحرب
ثالثا اعاده النظر في مبادئ ميثاق الامم
المتحده لكي تتناغم اكثر مع رؤيه روسيا
رابعا اعاده النظر في اتفاقيه مانسك لوقف
القتال في بومباس
وبعيدا عن امكانيه التفاوض من عدمه تتواصل
الحرب على ارض الميدان حرب يرى الرئيس
الروسي فالديمر بوتين ان انتصار روسيا
فيها امر حتميه بوتين اكد ايضا ان بلاده
حاولت حل المشاكل العالقه مع اوكرانيه
بشكل سلمي لكن لم يكن هناك حل سوى الدخول
في الحرب
تيوب
لم تتوقف العمليات القتاليه التي تشمل
الاسلحه الثقيله والمدفعيه والدبابات
والطائرات في دمباز منذ 2014 ما نقوم به
اليوم كجزء من العمليه العسكريه الخاصه هو
ومحاوله لوقف هذه الحرب وحمايه شعبنا الذي
يعيش في تلك المناطق لقد تحملنا لفتره
طويله وحاولنا التوصل الى اتفاق لكن تم
خداعنا وهذه ليست المره الاولى ومع ذلك
بدلنا قصار جهدنا لحل هذا الوضع بالوسائل
السلميه العدو كان يستعد لتحويل الصراع
برمته الى مرحله حاده وساخنه اكرر لم يكن
لدينا خيار سوى ان نفعل ما نقوم به الان
المشكله
لم يتاخر في الرد على تصريحات بوتن هذه
والتي اعتبر انها لا تخدم مساعي ايقاف
الحرب حيث يعتبر الامير العام للحلفيان
برج ان فوتن لم يبعث اي اشاره على
استعداده للسلام مؤكدا ان روسيا لن تفوز
في الحرب
وفيما يتعلق بامدادات الاسلحه اكدستلتون
برج ان المشاورات المستمره بين الحلفاء
لتزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات قتاليه كما شدد
امين عام حلف الناتو على ضروره توفير
المزيد من الاسلحه كيف في هذه الفتره
الفاصله من الحرب على حد وصفه
وتصريحات الامين العام للحلف سبقتها ايضا
تحذيرات من نائبه ادعى فيها الى ضروره
توخي الحذر من خطوره روسيا التي تستعد
لحرب طويله الامد على حد تعبيره
من شان روسيا امر خطير الرئيس الروسي
يستعد لحرب طويله وقد حشد بالفعل اكثر من
200,000 جندي اضافي كثير منهم قيد التدريب
بوتين يتوسعوا في الانتاج العسكري الروسي
ويحصل على المزيد من الاسلحه من الانظمه
الاستبداديه الاخرى في ذلك ايران ليس
لدينا ما يشير الى ان اهدافه بوتين قد
تغيرت لذلك يجب ان نكون على كامل الجاهزيه
والاستعداد العام الحالي سيكون صعبا ونحن
بحاجه الى تقديم المزيد من الدعم لاوكانيا
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه هل ينجو بايد من
قضيه الملفات السريه معطن قانوني جديد قد
ينقذ الرايس
[موسيقى]
مرحبا من جديد خطوه او رفيه لافته في
سياسه الضغط على النظام الايراني فقد وافق
البرلمان الاوروبي اخيرا على مشروع قرار
يطالب الاتحاد الاوروبي بادراج المرشد
الايراني علي الخامنائي ورئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيس على قوائم العقوبات ودعا
مشروع القرار ايضا الى ادراج الحرس الثوري
الايراني والباسيج على لائحه الارهاب كما
طالب البرلمان الاوروبي في مشروع قراره
بادراج جميع نواب البرلمان الايرانيه على
قوائم العقوبات والافراج الفوري عن
الرعايه الاوربيه
في المقابل قال النائبه في البرلمان
الايراني اسماعيل كوثري انه يجب على دول
اوروبا اثبات استقلالها عن امريكا ومعارضه
اي عمل ضد الحرس الثوري الايراني مشيرا
بان ادراج الحرس الثوري ضمن قائمه
الجماعات الارهابيه يغلق اي باب للحوار
والتفاوض مهددا بان ايران تعلم ما الذي
يجب عليه فعله اذا قام الاتحاد الاوروبي
بهذا الفعل
نور الدين فريدي مراسلنا من بروكسيل معنا
من هناك مباشره على الهواء نور الدين اهلا
بك معنا تفاصيل ما ينوي الاتحاد الاوروبي
فرضه من عقوبات على المرشد الايراني
الرئيس الايراني وكذلك الحرس الثوري
والمسيح
مساء الخير صهيب مساء النور يجب ربما هناك
حاجه للتوضيح هذا موقف البرلمان الاوروبي
الذي صعد في بيانه وهو تقريبا
بما يشبه الاعلان او الرغبه المعلنه
بالقطيعه النهائيه مع النظام الايراني لكن
هذا البيان ليس ملزما للدول الاعضاء ليس
ملزما للدبلوماسيه الاوروبيه وليس ملزما
لجوزيل انما موقف البرلمان هو يعكس المزاج
السياسي للراي العام المزاج السياسي
للمختلف الكتل السياسيه ياخذ بعين
الاعتبار يسرى له همم تراجعه الدبلوماسيه
الاوروبيه ولكن القرار الحقيقي هو ليس في
هذا في هذا البيان او في البيانات الاخرى
التي يصدرها البرلمان الاوروبيه من
صلاحياته السياسه الخارجيه ان انه له
صلاحيه الاستشاره بما انه مجرد رايي ومجرد
صحيح بينما عمليا ما حدث اليوم اييه بشكل
ملموس هو ما حدد فيه بروكسل وليس مظبوط
وفي بروكسل هناك توافق سياسي بين
الدبلوماسيين الاوروبيين وممثلين الدول
الاعضاء 27 اي الحكومات حول
حزمه رابعه من العقوبات ستفرض وست ستصادق
عليها يوم الاثنين المقبل طيب نور الدين
في حال تم الاستجابه لهذه الدعوه من قبل
البرلمان الاوروبي همم ما الذي سيترتب على
عليها على هذه الاجراءات الاوروبيه ضد همم
ايران وعلى المرشد وعلى الرئيس كذلك
ربما لن يترتب شيء لان هذا الامر لم يحدث
اقله في هذه المرحله
هذه الايام هي مساله الحرس الثوري
الايراني ومساله ادراجه في قوائم الارهابي
ليس فقط البرلمان انما تطرحها المانيا
تطرحها هولندا تطرح جمهوريه التشيك فرنسا
قالت انها منفتح عليها وبالتالي هذه
النقطه هي النقطه الرئيسيه المطروعه على
الصعيد الدبلوماسي لكن عمليا لم ااه تنقل
بعده هذه صحيحه
ولكن هذه الدعوه كما تفضل يعني في معرض
حديثك هي تعكس نوعا من تغير المزاج
الاوربي او حاله راي عام تشكلت الان او
بدات تتشكل بشكل واضح ضد ممارسات النظام
الايراني همم يعني الى اي احد هذا الصوت
طاغي او هذا المزاج همم بات اكثر فاكثر من
دعنا نقول همم لدى المسؤولين الاوروبيين
الان وما الذي ولما الذي ادى به الى كذلك
ما اسباب تغير هذا المزاج
طمع السلطات الايرانيه المنهج والفضيع
للاحتجاجات المتواصله منذ اشهر خروج
المراه والشباب والتحام المجتمع الايراني
بمختلف فئاته في مختلف المدن لان التقارير
كافه مجمعه حول هذا الامر حول هذه التعبئه
الشعبيه الشعارات التي رفعتها الوعي الذي
اظهره الشعب الايراني ثانيا سلوك ايران في
دعمها روسيا عسكريا هذا جعل او سهل على
الاوروبيين داخل البرلمان الاجماع حول
المطالبه تقريبا بالقطيعه النهائيه
والتامه مع النظام الايراني هذا هو مغزى
بيان البرلمان الاوروبي وقراره هو هناك
قطاعات سياسيه واسعه جدا مستعده اليوم
للدعوه لقطيعه النهائيه والتامه مع النظام
الايراني طبعا الدبلوماسيه من دورها من
طبيعتها الباحث عن همم ابلاغ الراي شرح
هذا الراي وهمم ساعده على حل هذه المشكله
ما تقوم به الدبلوماسيه الاوروبيه اذا هي
مشخصه في جوزيف بوراك لكن الدبلوماسيه
ليست ثابته هناك تطور نراه خاصه في مواقف
بعض الدول مثل المانيا شكرا جزيلا لك
نوردين فريدي مباشره من بروكسل
[موسيقى]
في جلسه نقاشيه في منتدى دبوس اكد وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
انه لا يمكن انهاء الحرب في اليمن الا من
خلال حل يتم الاتفاق عليه بين الاطراف
كونان لا يمكن انهاء الحرب الا من خلال حل
نتفق عليه وهذا ما نعمل عليه حاليا
المبعوث الخاص للامم المتحده المعاني
باليمن موجود هنا وحكومه اليمن تسعى ايضا
لايجاد وسيله للاتفاق مع الحوثيين للوصول
الى وقف اطلاق النار والوصول الى نهايه
هذه الازمه من جانبه شديد
على ضروره انهاء الصراع في اليمن مؤكدا ان
الحرب تسببت في معاناه الملايين
الصراع في اليمن لا يخدم احدا ويتسبب في
المعاناه للملايين الهدف هو ايجاد وسيله
لانهاء الصراع كيف وعلى اي اسس هذه امور
يمكن تفاوض بشانها الخطوات التي تم
احرازها كانت ايجابيه في الاشهر الاخيره
حيث خفض صوت السلاح لكن الموضوع لم ينتهي
والطريق لا يزال طويلا
[موسيقى]
يضرب رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنا منه
اخماسا باسداس لمواجهه قرار المحكمه
العليا
بشقب تعيين رئيس حزب شخص اردني واحد اهم
اركان حكومه
وزيرا في حكومه بسبب ادانته السابقه بقضيه
فساد الملك في اول رد لي على القرار قال
اذا اغلق الباب في وجهنا سندخل من النافذه
يتنياهو الحكومي من المحكمه العليا
الاسرائيليه التي قررت باغلبيه عشره قضاه
في مقابل معارضه واحد الغاء تعيين رئيس
حزب شاسه درعي وزيرا في الحكومه بسبب
ادانته في قضيه فساد ما يعني ان على
نتنياهو ان يقيله من منصبه وما يعني ايضا
بان الحرب على النظام القضائي التي تسميها
الحكومه اصلاحات ستستعر ازواج دستوريه
وربما
ازمايتيه ولكن مما لا شك فيه هناك ازمه
بين السلطه القضائيه والسلطه التنفيذيه هي
الحكومه في سبب اقاله الوزير همم
اللافته ان قرار المحكمه العليا جاء رغم
قيام وزير العدل الاسرائيلي بعرض خطبه
اضعاف القضاء عشيه المداولات في ملف درعي
معتبر تهديدا للنظام القضائي الاسرائيلي
الذي يحاكم نتنياهو
ثلاث قضايا فساد
يتجاوزت كل الحدود بالتدخل في قانون اساسي
اقر باغلبيه 63 شخصا عكس رغبه الاغلبيه
للاسف المحكمه العليا تعتقد بانها حاكم
خفي لاسرائيل
تخالف القانون وحكومه لا تلتزم بالقانون
هي حكومه غير قانونيه
الائتلاف سيسرع التشريعات المتعلقه
بالقضاء بهدف محاوله اعاده درع الى منصبه
ومن بينها تغليب قرارات الكنيست على
قرارات القضاء وتامين اغلبيه للسياسيين من
الاحتلال في لجنه تعيين القضاء والغاء
فقره المعقوليه القضائيه كالتي حسمت امر
درعي باعتبار انه غير معقول ان يبقى وزيرا
بعد ايداداته المتكرره بقضايا فساد الملك
المعركه بين التوليفه الحاكمه في اسرائيل
ونظام القضائيه شهدت نقله نوعيه بالغاء
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه توزير درعي
تصب الزيت على نار المواجهه الدائره في
البرلمان وفي الشارع الاسرائيلي ايضا زياد
حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه
[موسيقى]
هل ينجو الرئيس الامريكي من قضيه الملفات
السريه التي احتفظ بها معطن جديد
في مصلحه الرئيس الامريكي هنا عن قانون
التقادم التاكيد جاء نقلا عنك وهو محامي
امريكي
لا يواجه عقوبه القانونيه وذلك استنادا
لقانون التقادم الذي يقضي بالغاء اي تهمه
في قضيه مره خمس سنوات على حدودها وتعود
الاوراق السري التي تم العثور عليها في
احد مكاتبنا السابقه
وفي منزله
للفتره التي كان يشتغل فيها منصبه نائب
الرئيس اوباما ما بين سنتين 2009 و2017
صاحب هذه التصريحات معنا مباشره من
نيويورك نك اكرمان المدعي العام السابقه
في وترجيت ومساعد المدعي العام الامريكي
سيد اكرمان شكرا جزيلا لك على انضمامك
الينا الليله في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
هل فعلا مساله التقادم ومرور خمس سنوات
على احتفاظ رئيس بهذه الوثائق ستخرجه
سالما من قضيه الملفات السريه
[موسيقى]
همم
يؤكد على فتره خمس سنوات
او يكشف عنها بطريقه تعارض المصالح
الامريكيه فهذا يكون انتهاك اللي قانوني
عنصر في هذه القضيه ففي ما يخص الرئيس
فهذه قضيه مختلفه همم
وجداها عكس ترامب الذي اعتقد بالوثائق
لعام ورفض التسليم هذه الوثائق التي اخذها
معه عندما غادر البيت الابيض ثم سلم مع
الوثائق ولم يسلم كل هذا ثم تلقى امرا
بعدده الوثائق كلها ولكنه احتفظ ببعض
وزاره
التفتيش وتم العثور على همم الوثائق اخرى
وبالتالي همم
مختلفتان تماما بالنسبه للترامب المساله
تتعلق باخفاء الوثائق واعاقه العداله وهذا
مختلف تماما عن قضيه الرئيس
ال قضيه وثائق ترامب السريه وجوبايدن
تختلفان من حيث كما ذكرت التقادم المده
الزمنيه وكذلك التعاون مع العداله ولكن
الا تخشون ان يكون هناك همم يعني هجوم همم
على همم القضاء او على المدعي العام هنا
بان هناك معامله تفضيليه للرئيس جوبيد
خاصه وانه ترامب نفسه يقول انه قضيه همم
تفتيش اقامته في مارالغو همم كانت مسيسه
بناء على مذكره اصدرها لان دونالد ترامب
هي اعاده كل الوسائل وبالتالي في الحكومه
ادرك انه لا يزال يحتفل وثائق سريه وانه
كذب همم
فهذا الرئيس
منتهيه ولما كان ال ال كانت العداله قد
اصدرت مذكره تفتيش للاقامه اشكرك شكرا
جزيلا على هذه المدخله معنا من نيويورك
اكرمان المدعي العام السابق في ووتر جيت
ومساعد المدعي العام الامريكي
[موسيقى]
نبقى في امريكا الملياردير لهم ماسك قد
يدفعوا غاليا ثمنا بضعه احرف كتبها في
تغريده قصيره القضيه تعود الى صيف سنه
2018 حين غرد ماسك بانه يريد اخراج تيسلا
من البورصه لانه همم له ما يكفي من
التمويل للقيام بذلك
هي كلمات قليله صحيح ولكنها تسببت في هزه
على مستوى اسهم الشركه في حيث تارجح السهم
بشكل حاد لبضعه ايام بعد تغريده لهم مصر
والان وبعد اكثر من اربع سنوات على هذه
الواقعه بدات بشكل فعلي محاكمه ماسك في
محكمه بسام فرانسيسكو والتهمه الموجهه
اليه من مساهميه الشركه هي التلاعب بسعر
السهم ويزعم المتهمون ان هذه التغريده
كانت خاطئه من حيث الوقائع واثرت بشكل
مصطنع على سعر سهم
تغريده ماسك احاطت بها مشاكل عده فقبل
انطلاق محاكمه كانت هيئه الاوراق الماليه
والبورصات قد فرضت غرامه قدرها 20 مليون
دولار على ماسك بدعوه عدم تقديم الدله على
امتلاكه التمويل اللازم من اجل نقل تسلا
الى ملكيه خاصه كما اجبرته على التخلي عن
رئاسه مجلس اداره تسلا وطالبت لاحقا بان
تتم الموافقه المسبقه على تغريداته
المتعلقه بنشاط تسلا من محامي مختص
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه الصين مقبله على
سيناريوم مرعب بسبب موجه تفشل فتاكه
لكرونا في البلاد
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد
على الكثير من بقاع العالم وارقامهم غير
مسبوقه تدق ناقوس الخطر من حدوث مجاعات في
الكثير من الدول منتدى دابست للاقتصاد
العالمي لم يمر دون التحذير من ازمه
الرداء الاسود
في تصريحات لصحيفه الشرق الاوسط من تفاقم
ازمه الغذائي في العالم معبرا في الوقت
نفسه عن قلقه من ارتفاع مستويات فقط
لغه الارقام تكشف بالملموس ارتفاع مستوى
الجوع في العالم الى حد مغلق في برنامج
غذائي العالمي اكد ان عام 2022 كان عاما
غير مسبوق من الجوع حيث ان عدد الاشخاص
الذين يواجهون انعدام الامن الغذائي الحاد
ارتفع من 135 مليون الى 345 مليون منذ عام
2019 اي في ظرف ثلاث سنوات فقط كما انبها
برنامج الغذاء العالمي الى ان هناك نحو 50
مليون شخص على شفا المجاعه في سنه 2020 من
جهاتها حذرت الامم المتحده من تفاقم ازمه
الغذاء على مستوى العالم مؤكده ان نحو 30
مليون طفل حول العالم يواجهون شبح المجاعه
او الواو
بالازمه الاقتصاديه العالميه حيث ان
التوقعات غير مباشره كما تواجه اجزاء
كثيره من العالم ركودا اقتصاديا ويواجه
العالم باسره تباطئ في النمو وتفاق من في
عدم المساواه فضلا عن ازمه في تكاليف
المعيشه وهي الازمه التي تتفاقم بسرعه
الان ما اسباب زياده ازمه الغذاء حول
العالم خلال الفتره الماضيه برنامج الغذاء
العالمي اكد اضطراب سلاسل التوريد منذ
جايحه كورونا» ما ادى الى ارتفاع الهائل
في تكاليف الغذاء في 2020 ونقل عن برنامج
الغذاء العالمي فان اسعار المواد الغذائيه
ارتفعت بنحو 20% على اساسا سنويا كما ان
التغيرات المناخيه وما رافقها من ارتفاع
في درجات الحراره ومن فيضانات وجفاف ادت
الى تراجع المحاصيل في العديد من البلدان
واشتداد وازمه الغذاء لم يكن في من انا عن
ارتفاع معدلات الفقر حول العالم حيث من
المتوقع ان يعاني نحو سبعه في المئه من
سكان العالم من الفقر المتقع الى حدود عام
2030 وذلك نقلا عن تقرير للبنك الدولي هذا
وبلغ عدد الاشخاص الذين يعيشون في فقره
متقع مع نهايه السنه الماضيه نحو
685 مليون شخص ما يجعل عام 2022 ثاني اسوء
عام على مستوى جهود الحد من الفقر في
العقدين بعد عام 2020
للمزيد من التفاصيل معنا من القاهره عبد
العطيفه مديره الوحده الاقليميه للاعلام
في برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه العالميه مرحبا بك معنا استاذ
عبير في اخبار الساعه هذا المساء من
العربيه الدول العربيه ما محلها في ازمه
الجوع هذا التي يتم الحديث عنها في نابلس
بيواجه ازمه غذاء غير مسبوقه وطبعا الدول
العربيه ودول منطقه الشرق الاوسط ليست في
مناى عن هذه الازمه وهي اكبر ازمه بيشهدها
التاريخ الحديث همم الملايين بيتعرضوا
للخطر تفقم الجوع وكما ذكرت هناك طبعا
عوامل كثيره نزاعات الصدمات المناخيه خطر
الركود العالمي همم عمليه التضخم همم
الاقتصاد المتدهور من اثار جراء طبعا ما
بعد رائحه الكورونا واثار ازمه اوكرانيا
كل هذه العوامل بتنطبق على المنطقه
العربيه همم هناك العديد من الصراعات
المسلحه او عدم الاستقرار السياسي الذي
همم ما ما ما
يخيم شمعه على هذه المنطقه طبعا التغيرات
المناخيه بتضرب كثير من المناطق في الدول
عربيه همم هناك همم طبعا نقص شديد في
المياه همم وفي عمليه جفاف في كثير من
المناطق بتؤثر على الزراعه بالاضافه ايضا
الى عمليه الركود الاقتصادي وتدهور اا
اسعار العمله في كثير من العملات المحليه
في كثير من الدول العربيه كل هذه العوامل
همم بتجعل المنطقه العربيه من اكثر
المناطق التي ستكون عرضه لا تذبذب في
اسعار المواد الغذائيه وعمليه التضخم في
اسعار الغذاء هل هناك دول عربيه افضل من
غيرها افضل حالا من غيرها ام ان هذا الحال
يعم الجميع يعني المنطقه العربيه كلها
ودول العالم كافه يعني في همم كلنا في
الهم سوا
يعني بصوره عامه اكيد طبعا الدول المنتجه
للبترول هي اقل تاثرا لان اسعار البترول
في زياده وبالتالي لن يكون هناك تاثر كبير
في هذه الدول على عمليه وجود الغذاء او
يعني توفر الغذاء ولكن يعني ما زالت هذه
الدول اا يعني ستكون معتمده على استيراد
المواد الغذائيه بصوره كبيره همم اما طبعا
الدول التي همم يعني همم يعني تعاني
بالفعل من ازماتك اقتصاديه وكثير من هذه
الدول لبنان مصر الاردن همم طبعا
الظروف الاقتصاديه التي
ايضا تضرب بالعراق بسوريا بسرعه عامه ايضا
مناطق دول شمال افريقيا
هل هناك اي من اجراءات يمكن القيام بها
للتخسيس من وطاه هذه الازمه الغذائيه
هو طبعا يعني يجب ان يكون هناك تعامل مع
هذه الازمه بصوره سريعه من قبل الحكومات
هذه الدول عمليه دعم الغذاء واستمرار دعم
الفئات الاكثر فقرا والاكثر عرضه للجوع
بالاضافه ايضا الى عمل المنظمات الانسانيه
والاغاثيه كبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي وغيرهم
وايضا توفر
الاموال من الدول المناحه
والمجتماعات الماليه بصوره عامه للبنك
الدولي حتى يكون هناك شبكات امان اجتماعي
للاكثر فقط لكن طبعا همم الازمه ايضا في
العالم الان انها ليست فقط ارتفاع في
اسعار المواد الغذائيه ربما سيشهد هذا
العالم العام نقص في وفره المواد الغذائيه
وهذه ستكون بالفعل ضربه اا للاكثر جوعا
اكثر فقا في دول المنطقه وبدانا بالفعل
نشهد نقص في المواد الغذائيه في بعض السلع
الاستراتيجيه كازيوت وكالارز ودقيق القمح
للوحده الاقليميه للاعلام في برنامج
الاغذيه العالم
لم تستفق الصين من كابوسها كابوس كورونا
بعد فهي مقبله على سيناريو مرعب بحسب
تحليل لشركه ابحاث بريطانيا التحليل يرجح
ان تشهد الصين
وقد يشكل عبئا كبيرا على نظام رعايه
الصحيه في البلاد ورفض التحليل ان
الاصابات بلغ الذرواتها في بعض المقاطعه
مثل شنغهاي ويونان وغيرها بعد الغاء قيود
سياسه صفر فيما انتشر الفيروس بسرعه اكبر
من المتوقع في المناطق الريفيه مدفوعه
الجزئيه للسفر للاحتفالات بالعام الصيني
الجديد ولعل هذه الصوره التي التقطت اليوم
للمسافرين في محطه قطارات شنغهاي تنقل لنا
الوضع عن قرب في الصين
واذا ما تحدثنا بالارقام حول هذه الموجه
الفتاكه رجح التقرير ارتفاع عدد الوفيات
جراء كورونا في الصين الى 36 الف الوفاه
يوميا وتقدر الشركه البريطانيه ان وفيات
كورونا الاجماليه في الصين تجاوزت 600 الف
وثلاث منذ ديسمبر الماضي رقم قياسيه
وقفزات تظهر الوتيره السريعه لتفرشي
الفيروس ونقص المعلومات الواضحه حول كيفيه
انتشاره في اكبر دوله في العالم من حيث
السكان
[موسيقى]
في اسبوع واحد توفي
انخفاض الدرجه
[موسيقى]
ختام واخبار الساعه
البيت الابيض
السياسيه عبر ساحه المعركه
البرلمان الاوروبيه يدعوا لادراجي خامنئي
ورئيسي على قوائم العقوبات والحرس الثوري
على قوائم الارهاب
معركه نتنياهو مع القضاء تستعر بعد الغاء
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه تعيين اريد
درعي وزيرا في الحكومه
بعد ازمه الركود شبح الجوع يخيم على اعمال
منتدى دابوس مجاعه غير مسبوقه تدق ناقوس
الخطر في العالم
شكرا لكم على كلام المشاهده المزيد دائما
على العربيه
[موسيقى]